good evening everyone my name is Vicki
Goodman and on behalf of the friends of
the Semel Institute for Neuroscience and
human behavior at UCLA it is my pleasure
to welcome you to this open mind
presentation we are honored and proud to
have with us this evening a preeminent
scientist who really needs no
introduction to this audience our
director of the Semel Institute and
author of the mood apart American mania
and the well-tuned brain neuroscience
and the life well-lived which is the
book that dr. Peter Y brow will be
talking about this evening welcome dr. Y
brow thank you so much for coming to
speak with us this evening this is a
real treat for so many of us we even
have people here from Oxford from France
and we are just delighted to welcome you
this evening joining dr. Y brow in
discussion will be another preeminent
scientists from the Semel Institute dr.
Andrew Luc der who is a professor of
psychiatry and bio behavioral sciences
and the director of the neuromodulation
Center at the Semel Institute he's also
our faculty advisor so we would like to
up thank dr. Luke der also for being
here this evening and for sharing his
knowledge and expertise with us a few
housekeeping items after the
presentation we will have a discussion
that dr. Luther is going to moderate you
will receive if you would like to ask a
question please pick up an index card
that will be passed around by some of
our board members write your question on
the index card and someone will come by
to pick it up we will not be taking any
questions directly from the floor so if
you'd like to ask a question please
sure to use the index card then after
the Q&A you will have the opportunity if
you've not already done so to purchase a
copy of dr. Y browse book and have it
personally signed by him and now before
I introduce dr. Y Brown I just would
like to say a few words about the
friends and our open mind program as
most of you know the friends sponsor the
open mind as a public service to the
community at no charge what you may not
know is that there is a cost to putting
on these programs we are a UCLA support
group but we still have to pay for the
rentals of auditoriums honorariums for
our distinguished speakers many who come
from out of town and we have to play
airfare and lodging so if you have not
already done so in the spirit of the
holidays and the spirit of giving we
hope that you will support our
organization we really need your help so
that we can continue to bring these
programs to the UCLA community and the
Los Angeles community as a public
service and not charge for them
givingtuesday which is the National Day
of Giving is on December 1st it's a
perfect opportunity to join the entire
nation and support an organization that
has given you this really excellent
programming this year that I know that
you've all been coming and if you feel
you that it has been beneficial please
support us I'd now like to introduce dr.
Peter Y brow in addition to being the
director of the Semel Institute for
Neuroscience and human behavior at UCLA
dr. Y brow is also the Judson Bron
distinguished professor and executive
chair of the department of psychiatry
and bio behavioral sciences at the David
Geffen School of Medicine and also the
CEO of the Resnick neuropsychiatric
hospital he is an international
authority on emotion and it's disorders
particularly depression and bipolar
illness and the effects of thyroid
hormone on brain and human behavior in
the well tuned brain dr. Y brow offers
us a prescription for genuine human
progress and takes us on a fascinating
tour of self-discovery drawing
extensively upon his decades of
experience as a psychiatrist and his
broad knowledge of neuroscience and
human behavior ladies and gentlemen
please join me in giving a warm welcome
to dr. Peter Y Brown Thank You Vicki and
good evening everybody
it's good to see you here this is quite
an evening for me it's I don't know one
doesn't usually get celebrated by one's
own Institute so I I feel very grateful
a little a little actually a little
humbled that all these bits and pieces
here we had to move my desk out of my
office because we couldn't quite figure
out how to do all this we have a carpet
I don't know where that came from it was
it one doesn't know about one's own
place does one so this new book is one
that began at least I started thinking
about it after the episode of the
financial meltdown in 2008 because it
intrigued me I mean it when we think of
our great country and we wonder how
could we possibly ever have imagined
that we could exist primarily on debt
and speculation it's intriguing because
you know one can see it as a moral issue
but one might also want to have to look
at it more precisely as perhaps a
neuropsychiatric behavioral issue and so
I began to wonder whether you could
detect out from that particular debacle
something that
might make sense that would take us out
of the moral realm and put us in a more
constructive realm about how we might
see this into the future and avoid it
because it doesn't look as if we have as
we run up to another bubble it seems to
me with the quantitative easing and so
on and so forth but it was a it was a
worthy cause and it allowed me to bring
all my interests of history and
economics and a few other bits and
pieces together to find out in my own
mind why it is that we don't do better I
mean we have such material success but
somehow it doesn't quite work in terms
of human progress one of the things that
strikes me is that in my lifetime the
population of the world has increased
its doubled actually but the economic
output has increased by eight fold in
the same 50 years 50 60 years that is
extraordinarily striking so one wonders
given that we as a nation are only four
percent of the population of the world
but we consume in the traded resources
something like 25 percent one wonders
why it is that we're not doing better
than we are because yes of course we're
rich but if you look at the statistics
we are in terms of our social parameters
and other things we're sort of in the
middle of the pack when one does how
could that be is there some strange
correlation here between what we do and
the fact that we have certain personal
health problems and we worry about the
environment objectively I think etc etc
so in that 50 years if you look at the
world at large there's no doubt that our
health and our wealth have improved
enormous Li most of the children that we
bear these days in the world grow to
maturity we are literate in general
we're very successful and yet then when
you look at the US we have many skurge
ha's which plagued us one of which is
for example that we have a great deal of
obesity we actually are one of the
fattest countries in the world over 50%
of people on our obese especially males
white males so I think that we have to
ask ourselves questions about how did
this come about I don't think it need be
and so in this analysis which I'll talk
a little bit about tonight I what I'd
like to present to you is the idea that
it doesn't need to be we can actually do
things differently and have something
which if we look forward into the future
we would be able to avoid many of the
pitfalls that we found
there are now seven billion of us living
on this planet which is a larger burden
to the planet than any other large
animal species that has ever existed on
it so in some senses you have to think
of the age that we've now entered as the
age of man the Anthropocene you know
we've had 10,000 years of reasonably
stable environment and it's now shifting
you don't have to worry so much about
whether we've caused that shift or
whether in fact it is just shifting but
shifting it is and therefore we have to
think about how do we do something about
it it becomes in the age of man our
responsibility to think forward and to
ask ourselves why is it that certain
things have gone off the boat you know
as Ogden Nash said the American humorist
and poet just before he died in 1971 he
said progress might have been alright
once but it has gone on too long so
that's really the Impractical terms what
the new book is about I think that if we
wish to reshape the future we need first
to understand ourselves and reshape our
own behavior that's the fundamental
thrust of the well-tuned brain
if we could accomplish that in this
great country we would give great
service to everybody because there's no
doubt that people look to the US for the
future and yet we ourselves are not very
good at looking at the future asked two
questions to myself when I started this
book and I asked him to you tonight why
is it that human beings tend to consume
excessively when living in a resource
rich environment think about that the
more affluent we get the worse our
health gets in many ways why despite our
growing consciousness and awareness of
these things of ecological problems
obesity stress lack of trust increasing
debt we know about all these things but
we don't change them we worry about them
but it seems as if we are powerless to
change our behavior why is that these
are two interesting neuro behavioral
questions which I think are open to
reason and open to an analysis that we
can bear upon them from what we know
about advancing neuroscience and I'm not
just talking here about molecular
biology I'm talking about what we know
about the way in which human beings
behave towards each other and how the
brain works you know one of the things
that I as I began to think about these
things that became apparent to me is
that one way of thinking about it is
that we are caught in a mismatch that
there's evolution the biological
evolution proceeds slowly of course and
so does cultural evolution that they do
so at different speeds cultural
evolution is much more rapid than
biological evolution and it's probable
that if you analyze that that in fact
they we have found ourselves now in a
cleft stick because some of the things
that we've been so creative in invent
have created for us for ourselves a
biological problem which we can't fix
just by pretending that new technology
will bring us to a better place
so while I'm going to propose to you
tonight is that in evolution returns we
have promoted a mismatch inadvertently
and there are three elements which I
will talk about ancient instinctual
strivings that seek short-term reward
I'll tell you a little bit about that
the material affluence of our
contemporary society and the third thing
which is an efficient habit driven brain
all these things of themselves are
somewhat positive but put them together
it's a perfect storm what has happened
is that we find ourselves in the middle
of this perfect storm without really
understanding it and it's washing away
much of our better selves so that's the
fundamental thesis of the book I'm only
going to talk about the first half I
will then touch upon the second half the
first half is called who do you think
you are the second part is how to live
both of them are questions
succinctly I think what we run into and
this is where the title comes in the
human brain is not well tuned for our
modern culture you know if you think of
biological evolution as Darwin conceived
of it and we've now validated it in many
ways it's just a gradual process of
variation selection variation of the
species selection of the biology that is
presented to the environment and then
replication of that variation it's
something that we have very little
control over we might think we can
re-engineer the human frame but actually
we're passive in that regard
so we no longer me no more control our
biology than does the darwin finch that
he wrote so eloquently about in his in
his in his writings of the late 1800s it
has no grand purpose no grand purpose at
all human culture on the other hand does
have grand purpose at least we infuse it
with grand purpose we think of it as
progress as a movement towards some
better place but what I would suggest to
you is that is not necessarily where we
end up think about just obesity that I
mentioned a little earlier if you mix
modern culture fast food no exercise
time stress with our ancient biology you
end up with obesity on the one hand you
could consider the ability to move
rapidly to eat quickly to not have to
worry about opening the garage door as
being progress but it obviously has a
deleterious effect on some of our
physiology
so let's look at a slide here and ask a
question about the way in which this
could possibly have come about this is
just a a I have to remember to speak
carefully into the microphone because of
the c-span this is a an interesting
slide because it shows the geological
record mammals first began to appear
somewhere towards the end of the
dinosaur era some 60 million years ago
but the apes and men and individuals we
might now consider primate were about 20
million years ago and we came along the
hominids somewhere around here and Homo
sapiens is only perhaps two a hunt two
hundred thousand three hundred thousand
years old at the most and then when we
get to the age of man the Holocene was
the ten thousand years I mentioned
earlier the age of man really began when
we moved from hunting and gathering to
living together in various cultures
mainly through agriculture but nothing
very much changed the interesting point
is here this is the inflection point
you see suddenly we moved rapidly in
terms of our numbers we move from
scarcity into abundance both in terms of
numbers and in terms of our of our
culture so this is the interesting part
of the story so what actually happened
there
actually I think what happened was we
discovered liberty of which I will talk
about in a moment but we also discovered
science and fossil fuels that is the
secret to what has happened in the last
two or three hundred years the change in
the energy support this look a little
bit at the biology
now you can only really understand the
human brain if you think about it in
terms of evolution what I just spoke
about if you think of it as a cantaloupe
melon it's about the same size in the
middle of it there's all those seeds and
pithy stuff well that is the ancient
brain that is essentially the lizard
brain the brain that taught us how to be
competitive to survive the short-term
brain around that and it's called the
limbic brain and in fact it does mean
border so if you think of the first wave
of the flesh of the cantaloupe melon
that's that's the first limbic structure
that came about approximately when the
mammals began to be found on earth and
the mammals of course brought to our
understanding attachment and social
behavior lizards tend to eat their lot
young we don't do that at least not
anymore and the fact is that the way in
which we care for each other is a big
evolutionary advantage so that was
that's the next layer here and in the
brain it's reflected in this area that
you see there from there onwards it is
really just continued progression of
growth of the brain which we call the
cortex and the frontal cortex being of
course the outer rim and the frontal
lobes are things that have delivered for
us the extraordinary things that make us
human imagination the ability to reason
and especially to abstract region as
Hobbes said who you'll meet in a moment
there's no dog that does not know a
horse when he sees it and there's no dog
that does not know a man and when he
sees it but there's no dog that Hobbes
knew anyway and I don't know one either
that creates a scent or out of those two
things we are extremely clever creatures
we're also reward driven and competitive
just as that primitive brain was all
along and the attachment and the reason
that is layered upon the top of it
changes that way in which we are
competitive and self-interested but it
doesn't obscure it so they the things
need to move together if they are going
to be compatible in terms of the
behavior that we experience when
everything is what working together
it's an extraordinary machine but when
they don't work together and we see that
of course frequently in psychiatric
disorder things fall apart for example
you can imagine the outer cortex the
frontal cortex as the seat of Reason
which is what happened during the
Enlightenment years but the core of it
is passion and so the relationship
between reason and passion becomes
something similar in my mind I sometimes
tell the students it's rather like a
horse and a rider the horse is the
passion and when it starts to bolt if
the rider doesn't have a good bridle
then away goes the horse and so goes
reason with it it's also a little bit
like the title of my book which I take
from Jay s bark jeaious bark when he
went to Thomas kyoka in Leipzig in 1722
he wrote a book for his students called
the well-tempered clavier some of you
may know of it and it's a it's a series
of exercises for the students but it
also on the frontispiece teaches you how
to tune the harpsichord because in those
days the clavier the harpsichord was
notoriously out of tune just a changing
weather pattern or leaving it for a few
days the thing would go out of tune and
so bark in his consummate skill
recognized that if you're going to hare
an instrument like that that you were
going to play melodiously you had to
know the instrument - it's a metaphor of
course but you know we always in human
beings have always understood their
world in metaphor and so the way in
which I think of this book is that it's
really like the well-tuned brain being
like the well-tempered clavier if you
really want to know how to manage life
you have to not only understand the
interaction and be the musician of the
mind but you also have to know about the
instrument and so today as in the first
part of the book and talking about the
instrument when we play this instrument
well it is as I say extraordinary but
let's go back to that inflection let's
go back to the point where the biology
which had been there for millions of
years supercharged in the last two or
three hundred thousand years met
essentially the discovery of fossil
fuels you know until then we were
completely locked into the Worlds cycle
of energy which is essentially driven by
the Sun it's what we're experiencing now
as the northern hemisphere goes to sleep
we're expecting cold and there will be
nothing much growing at least not in
your hampshire which i will talk about
too but there may be something in
california but the fact is that we have
a cycle which is based upon the energy
of the sun that disappeared when we
discovered fossil fuel well the people
of that era
we call the Enlightenment thinkers the
Enlightenment thinkers were individuals
who just like we are but they were
fascinated by the country around them
and they were somewhat reticent to throw
over the Catholic Church and basically
say human beings could manage by
themselves Thomas Hobbes for example who
you will see down here in this corner he
had lived through the English Civil War
watched a few one King lose their head
and a few other people died and he was
convinced that there was no way in which
human beings could manage by themselves
we either needed a gain a king who was
very strict or you needed a God he
thought life was as he said nasty
brutish and short
burnin Mandeville however who was a
Dutchman in in the early 1700s the Dutch
were much more attuned to trade than
with the British and Mandeville was a
puckish fellow he come over when he was
in his 20s and he liked the English
sense of humor and he started to say
that actually Vice was a good thing the
vices were helpful because they employed
a lot of people and he had a little
doggerel which I don't know whether I
can find it yes luxury employed a
million of the poor and odious pride a
million more envy itself and vanity a
ministers of industry it's it's the
fundamental nature of the capitalist
enterprise that he was talking about and
he was
pushed aside by the English
establishment they said you know this is
ridiculous we can't possibly have people
doing what they want to do it just won't
work this was a time when the government
essentially controlled just about all
trade David Hume the next one on our
list he was much more sanguine about
these things he believed that yes reason
was the slave of the passions he was
much more understanding of the dynamics
of mind in fact he was a prophetic
fellow remember that these people knew
nothing about the anatomy or function of
brain but they were extraordinarily
capable of introspection and
understanding the way in which the human
being thought and so David Hume was very
influential in fact he was very
particularly influential on this younger
man here Adam Smith who as you know is
the patron saint of American capitalism
he's also I think somebody suggested to
me I think it was Meg Sullivan that the
reason why we did not get into the euro
is this thing here which is an English
20 pound note in which we have a picture
of Adam Smith and it says the division
of labour in pin manufacturing and the
great increase in the quantity of work
that resulted we all think of Adam Smith
as an economist the in fact he was a
psychologist he was a person who knew a
great deal about human behavior and in
1759 he wrote a book called the Moral
Sentiments it's a profound book which
talks about the way in which human
beings really behave and he points out
that human beings are not quite the same
way as Mandeville thought they were they
weren't just given device he was the man
who actually invented what we now call
empathy in terms of understanding of it
he has a beautiful passage in this
particular book in which he talks about
again metaphorically his brother being
on the rack you you cannot understand
the pain of your brother unless you
place yourself in
the brothers position being on the rack
yourself then you can understand it then
in that understanding you have sympathy
for him you're able to create again the
feelings which then enable you to be not
only sympathetic but you'll be able to
work with this individual to create a
new vision of their problem and help
them with that problem this of course is
what we talk about today in terms of the
engagement we must have as physicians or
as caring individuals we call it various
names what empathy is the core of it
compassion is another name we use for it
but he also wrote this book called The
Wealth of Nations in which basically he
said that human beings are
self-organizing you don't have to have
somebody from the top telling everybody
what to do what you can do is you can
just use the fact that they are intimate
with each other as I was just describing
and that you will find a natural order
of things in other words you can design
something without the aid of a designer
this of course is the great nature of a
democracy and it's very different from
the way in which fascist or top-down
communist type societies work where you
have an individual who knows they think
everything and therefore the order comes
down from the bottom it's the same way
in any institution that if you allow
people individually to to bring their
own initiative then you've got a
stronger program than if you've got
something just trickling down from the
top and he made these points the famous
one about you know you oh you're
yourself the butcher the candlestick
maker you live a good life by virtue of
their self-interest so Smith then argued
that the way in which a market society
should work is that yes indeed with
Mandeville you could let people have
their own initiative they could do what
they
wish'd but it had to be a closely knit
society there was an implicit social
contract which without that social
contract the thing wouldn't work and
that's a very important point because I
think what has happened to us is we have
lost the concept of the social contract
especially here in the US where we're
very individualistically driven you know
one of the one of the points of my last
book about American mania was not so
much that it were we were a friends in
society although we certainly are to
some degree but it was about migration
and the fact that migrants have an
individualistic view of the world they
are not as socially interdependent in
England where I grew up 60% of the
population still dies within 5 miles of
where they were born that's not true in
America so in these complex biological
systems a human being being one a social
organization being an hour another it's
the interaction of things which creates
the design and creates the stability
it's what scientists call a complex open
system so if we boil down the proposal
that Smith was making we can turn it
into neuro physiological
neuropsychological terms and this is how
the neuroscience of markets really works
in my mind
on the yellow box here we've got
self-interest curiosity
love of novelty and social ambition
which is essentially social competition
that's the engine of the market that's
what makes things go that's what makes
people get up in the morning that's the
entrepreneurial effort but on the other
side as Smith rightfully said it is the
sympathy the way in which we relate to
each other the empathic understanding
and the peer recognition which is
important we all want peer recognition
and without it you don't get anywhere
and so if you're a good boot maker you
make good boots but you also want your
your colleagues to know that you make
good boots and to buy them that's how it
works so this is the break on avarice
and hubris
you've got the engine on this side
self-love which he called it social
sentiment the brakes are on this side
and when you put these two things
together it's what he called it's
essentially an invisible hand which
makes the whole thing balance but we
have to remember that it's the social
contract between these two things this
arrow here which makes it work and so
now we come towards perhaps one of the
second factors of the mismatch if you
have a society which does not have a
closely knit social contract you're in
danger of creating an opportunity for
that instinctual drive to run free and
not necessarily to the advantage of the
society as a whole
let me just tell you we're very
short-term discounters this is just a
very short story keeping an eye on the
time here this is a very short story
there's a restaurant some of you may
know it in Westwood which is called the
Soleil I go there quite frequently
because I love their french fries
anyway one evening just after the new
year we were eating there I think
actually Susan Solomon was among the
party were three of us and we ate and we
enjoyed it and we had we were full up
and we had a glass of wine here and
there and we the the owner who is a
French Canadian came around and said are
you must try my new cheesecake you know
it's a wonderful cheesecake fresh
straight from Montreal the caramel
cheesecake we said no thank you we're
absolutely full he said oh no please
you're very crestfallen but anyway we
persuaded him he went away and we got
the bill and we paid the bill and then
suddenly he comes running out from
behind the where the kitchen is and he
presents this plate of cheesecake to us
sticks it in the middle of the table
gives us three forks and says oh now you
will try my wonderful cheesecake and so
we looked at each other and in about I
would say I'm not overestimating 90
seconds the thing had disappeared now
what does that tell us about human
beings that tells us that in fact we are
short-term in our vision I can stand
here and tell you that I am trying to
lose weight that I am not going to eat
cheesecake this coming new year I'm not
going to eat very much Thanksgiving etc
etc etc but when in the abstract I'm
very good at that
but when you put it in front of me I eat
it because this is the old lizard brain
waking up and saying boy that stuff it's
really good and I'm not going to lose
the opportunity to eat it when it's
placed in front of me so if you create
an affluent society where you're putting
metaphorically cheesecake in front of
somebody all the time what do we do we
eat it
it's a very different situation for the
one that where Smith conceived of the
modern market society and we still
believe we still hold him up as the
father of the market society with
forgotten half of what he talked about
yes look at this slide here I hope it's
not washed out for you at the back there
but it's a picture of a house it's
actually a house I bought when I first
came from England it's in New England
and it's in tiny village my daughter
happens to be a veterinarian there one
of my daughters but it still works
somewhat like it did in 1777 when the
when the house was built when people
have some sort of crisis her barn burned
down a couple of years ago and all they
lost all their all their wood supply for
the winter everybody was around giving
wood for the so they could they could
survive the winter it's a what we would
call a centric petal system a system
where the social networks here feed upon
each other so called social cohesion and
it's constrained by climate geography
and time let's look at this next one
this is today's society they took this a
picture in in in the Chicago Airport a
few months ago you can see I hope
although again it's unfortunately washed
out which is that here you have an
individual who is working at their
laptop you have somebody else playing
with their cell phone and here you have
somebody speaking on their cell phone
and then you've got the big plane that
takes them to another distant part this
is a centrifugal system where people are
moved away from each other you can't
easily have a system that Smith was
talking about when you have this type of
society that we now have the
globalization of trade and the internet
initiates this fast new world and we now
have got ourselves into the interesting
position where we are dependent upon
growth for the
economy so in fact we have to have
short-term reward and we have to feed it
in order to make the economy grow and
without that we all get worried that
we're now in another recession look at
the way the stock market's been bubbling
up and down recently everybody's
terrified of it are we going back into
another recession when we had the
disaster of the twin towers one of the
things that our good president said
within a few days was go out and shop
because we can't afford to have a
recession we have built ourselves a very
interesting Society which in fact is the
second part of my three elements this is
what's happening to us
we are actually fostering the short term
and we are diminishing the social
investment and the whole thing is moving
slightly to the right to your left
but the third element which is most
important of all is the intuitive habit
aspect of things you see one of the
things that the brain does is it's
extremely efficient and that efficiency
comes from habit just let's run an
experiment cross your arms for me okay
okay now uncross them and cross them the
other way you got it
you've got it right you see I had my arm
over here and now I've got to put this
arm under here and I've got difficult
isn't it that's an example of habit and
of course we have habits we're familiar
with them in the way we play tennis the
way to walk etc etcetera but that habit
is also going on inside your head you
have hundreds of social habits which you
have picked up over the years we call
them intuition intuitive habits which
you are not conscious of 80% of what we
do is pre conscious and so many of the
things we do day by day are habituated
and we don't even think about them you
remember the you remember the riot in
the los angeles school system when we
tried to move them from hamburger and
french fries for lunch to jambalaya and
wild rice there was a whole there was
literally a riot I think something like
you know 15 20 thousand students said
they weren't going to eat that stuff and
there was a there was a special market
that grew up outside for people to go
out and buy their french fries and their
hamburgers we're creatures of habit so
if we faster the habits that we have
they're very difficult to break
so the question then becomes how do we
begin to think about this in a way
that's constructive you know there's
another very interesting economist a
right-wing libertarian Friedrich Hayek I
happen to be a member of their society
which is always a surprise to me but I
think I'm the token biologist actually
but Hayek made this observation in the
20s and 30s he said that markets don't
run themselves they're not free in the
sense that we sometimes talk about them
in this country what what connects the
issues together is tradition what he
called tradition so it's the way in
which societies work is there as a
tradition which holds is the glue which
holds us all together now that is
essentially intuitive habit what goes on
then in the brain is that perception
comes in at the back and choice and
action are in the front with that so
this is where the limbic structures the
lizard brain and the infant brain of the
mammal meet the rational brain of the
frontal cortex but this is the basal
ganglia which runs the habit system and
it takes us as human beings somewhere
around 10 to 20 years to develop those
habits this is a slide from bucking
booster and in fact initially we just
combined together all the senses that we
have and we begin to understand how to
make action you've seen you've seen a
child trying to grasp the ball they
can't quite reach it they they go to it
but then they don't close their hand
fast enough or they close it before they
get to it but these actions are the
training of the habits of hand called
hand-eye coordination the same goes on
in your head in terms of social order
so the first part of the book says let's
try and figure out who we are who do we
really think we are let me read you the
beginning of the second part of the book
and then I'm going to close with a few
more remarks this is the prologue of the
second part how to live the Greeks call
it a tour Axia the state of being
unperturbed of tranquility and peace of
mind for Epicurus it was the foundation
of eudaimonia of the joy of human
flourishing 2,000 years on Adam Smith
was in agreement
Smith considered happiness to be born of
tranquility and enjoyment the fruit of a
well-tuned brain but human beings are
not given to serenity tranquility does
not come naturally to the human mind
ataraxia is a highly cultivated state
achieved through hard work and
self-discipline that we call character
such tuning arises from awareness of the
true nature of the world and an
understanding of the limitations the
limitations of our being to achieve such
self command which by the way was a word
that Smith used we must first accept
ourselves for who we are instinctively
driven curious self-interested focused
on the short term and ruled by habit not
a pretty picture
yes we combine that however with
extraordinary powers of reason of
perception analysis imagination and
choice but we are also deeply social and
need fellowship the challenge is to
bring these selves together in harmony
melding reason and passion to imagine a
sustainable human future that promotes
individual well-being and observes the
reality of our environmental
circumstance we are privileged to be
living in confusing times
nothing is more antithetical to the
cultivation of ataraxia than a debt
fueled consumer society which in its
promotion of material gluttony and
creeping in inequality flirts with
self-destruction in the ecological sense
but how do we dig out from under this
avalanche of modernity Adam Smith
considered three cardinal values
fairness benevolence and prudence to
underpin a stable social order these
elements of character are grounded in
the bonds of infancy and crafted over a
lifetime that's the world tune brain
crafted over a lifetime it's through
their nurturance and promotion that
social fellowships is exercised future
thriving is thus a matter of conscious
choice and shared responsibility healthy
children flourish in healthy families
healthy schools and healthy communities
collectively we thrive in habits that
are designed with humans in mind and
through markets that foster opportunity
and choice the mix has not changed by
embracing the past we can imagine the
future now you might wonder who this
young woman is this is my granddaughter
and she introduces the second part of
the book with a story she lives on a
sheep farm with my other daughter who's
a sheep farmer this is a lamb that she
rescued they have a tendency of taking
each other's lands you may not know that
because they get so hyped up with their
hormones just before they give birth
themselves that if another you gives
birth they was very often snatched the
lamb and take it away and the bonding
takes only a few minutes in the in the
cold of winter if that if the lamb is
not attached to the you literally for
milk it dies and so this is a very
interesting paradigm through which we
can understand because we have all the
same hormones oxytocin etc etc how human
attachment works what bonds a mother a
human mother to the child is the same as
what bonds are you to the lamb and what
Bond's Ren the name of my granddaughter
to this lamb that she fed in the kitchen
when it was stolen by another lamb and
when when the used own LAN was born it
was left asunder you see if we think of
the and this is the second half of the
book
is the thing that really binds us
together just think in your mind love is
the initial attachment but out of that
comes trust and it's within trust that
you begin to see your own ability to
command yourself that sheds into
education and once we get into school if
you have that sense of self command you
begin to learn and from there if we
build cities and habitat where we can
all be talking with each other that is
strengthened and when we eat around a
table rather than in the back of a car
it's strengthened there are so many
things we know about how to build human
beings we know what imagination means we
know all the things that create the
opportunity for a stable caring society
and yet we do not translate that into
social policy now why is that
ask yourself people ask me what's this
book about I say it's a mystery story we
know all these things but we do not
implement them we're the only country in
the world that does not have the
capacity to give young parents an
opportunity to spend time with their
children just born and go back to work
without losing their job
that's fascinating isn't it we're
stumbling towards a health care system
that's stumbling is the right word yeah
we can do so much better in terms of
thinking it's not a moral issue it's an
issue of how do you develop the best
form of human being you can develop how
do you chew in the brain in a way that
is to the benefit of all of us
one of the wonderful things about being
at the Semel Institute is that we have
the cemil's helping us see the future
Jane and Terry Semel some years ago
working with a group of us invented
something called the healthy campus
initiative we are trying to put in place
at UCLA this whole idea about how do you
create human beings who have their own
self-command
are empathic and are caring and you know
you don't just go to a university to
learn physics you learn also to
understand yourself and your fellow man
and woman so in doing that I think that
we've created an opportunity for the
future and we've just started again
wendy Schlosser has been extraordinary
in in leading the world well tuned the
well tuned campus the the healthy
initiative of the world toon campus but
we also we also have just started a
healthy mind project and that's
something which I think we will be
looking to over the next two or three
years and the friends is just an
exemplary organization in that regard
because what the friends does it brings
us together in a way that enables us to
learn the best from each other and I
think in doing that we will be able to
create a new society we have there are
pockets of these things going on all
over the country but it has to come up
from the bottom it's a design without a
designer and I think we will get there
but I want to thank you for coming
tonight because I think this is the sort
of gathering it's just the Friends of
the Semel Institute the Friends of the
Resnick Hospital that makes this change
possible so thank you so much
[Applause]
thank you very much for just a wonderful
presentation I know they'll be number of
questions from the audience and those of
you who do have questions there are
members of the friends circulating in
the aisles with questioning cards please
feel free to write down your questions
if you'd like me to be able to ask them
please write them so I can read them and
I'll do my best to work those into our
interview session here before we get to
questions from the audience Peter just
to get started with a couple of things
first for those of you who have not had
an opportunity to read the well - Dan
brained I highly recommend it it's a
really a wonderful wonderful work and I
think that one of the things I enjoyed
the most was really the panorama of
history that you were able to lay out
for the reader you know as you noted
Mark Twain is saying if history doesn't
repeat itself it certainly has a
tendency to rhyme and we've been doing
this to ourselves for a very long time I
mean the the patterns that you you write
that you spoke about this evening and
that you write about as you note in the
book brought down Bronze Age
civilizations were behind the tulipmania
of sixteen thirty one of the things I
learned was there was a tool at Manian
16:30 I wasn't aware of that as well as
being behind the 2008 stock market crash
so we've been these are these are long
ingrained patterns of behavior that we
inflict upon ourselves is this something
that we're going to be able to overcome
in our lifetimes
well my you just I don't know whether
this is on this one is though
the way I see it Andy is that I'm
basically an optimist at heart I guess
and I I think that America has an
extraordinary opportunity you know we've
always been somewhere ahead of the curve
in the last hundred years or so in terms
of developing material wealth but we
haven't really had a social contract
we're very much our origins which come
from that same enlightenment period that
the founding fathers knew but much more
about the Enlightenment thinkers than we
do today
and they essentially couched the
Constitution and the in in that rhetoric
in fact that's why we still think we can
take muzzleloaders guns around you know
and that we believe in the 18th century
so I think that if if in fact we ask
ourselves what is it that we can do now
I think it is to think through what you
were talking about and in take it out of
the moral realm you see it we we have
such a polarized political system at the
moment that it's almost as if you're
either for freedom or you're for
socialism and the two things don't meet
each other but of course they're really
basically the same thing we are the
social element of the contract that we
have to develop for the country to be
entrepreneurial but it has to each has
to feed the other so I think if we think
about what can we do if we took it out
of the moral realm and put it within an
a neuro science realm we can see why
this has happened to us
it's not a mystery as to why it is when
you when you goose the engine of the
marketplace but you forget the brakes
the whole thing runs off and when you
when you feed it with with money that
goes into the future or essentially
mortgaging your future so I think if we
if we come to think about it in these
terms it's possible that we'll be able
to say to ourselves you know this is
sort of crazy I mean we we are reasoning
creatures that's what distinguishes us
from the other creatures yes so if we're
reasoning why can't we go back to the
idea that the age of reason should be
reinvented now an America can do that I
think we can I think this mic is working
too well right now there thank you so
pardon me for a moment while I challenge
your optimism because I have had the
distinction of watching presidential
debates in the last week and you know we
we seem to live sometimes in a fact free
world you you were marveling at the end
of the talk about how we're not able to
adopt some of these basic principles
into our social discourse but you know
we're in a world where nearly half the
people think that evolution is just
another theory and the world is only
about 5,000 years old
we're global warming is a hoax where the
pyramids were built as grain silos and
where the answer to gun violence is just
make guns easier to get so it is almost
as though and you'll pardon the phrase
belief Trump's reason how is it that
we're going to get past this sort of
reflexive in some ways maladaptive
belief system that some people endorse
and get to a the kind of discourse that
you're talking about where we can begin
to reason our ways reason ourselves away
from this cycle of boom and bust that
we've become so accustomed to over the
centuries and which is getting worse
you're right yeah well you you hit the
right word it's reflexive you know we we
are reflexive creatures flawed largely
because 80% of what we do is try to have
it as I said
David Hume put it very well he said that
reason will is and always will be the
slave of the passions so in fact what he
was saying is what we're saying now
which is that you have one politician
who says you know all you've got to do
is to stick it to them and we'll be fine
the other says no we've got to organise
ourselves in a social order that is then
immediately taken as being essentially
top-down socialism both of them are
saying the same thing I think what
they're saying is that there's something
wrong here and we've got to find a
solution but they haven't really thought
through the solution and that both of
them are top-down solutions if you
follow me what I think is that and this
is why I'm optimistic you I'm I have no
apology for that because I do think if
you wonder what I do in this book is I
talk about a lot of people all the books
that I write have stories about people
in them and these are real people some
of the earlier books I wrote were about
patients and their experience and how
they managed to get out of those
problems american mania had a lot of
stories about people this also has a lot
of stories about people for example what
can we learn from a landscape our
consent er architect who is an expert on
renaissance villages in italy we can
learn a lot because renaissance villages
in italy sometimes didn't work and he
knows why they didn't work and so but
but the the stories the story of the
sheep farm for example the story of
there's a place in Culver City called
the the Museum of Jurassic technology if
you want to really goose your
imagination just go down there you will
find it a fascinating afternoon become
what I'm saying is there are whole
pockets of these things going on and I
think I sort of in my mind thought of
think of it rather like a series of
raindrops which have fallen and
eventually they coalesce
you've got a leak and I think that if if
we if we allow true social
entrepreneurship in the sense of being
willing to listen to each other then we
will find solutions that we cannot
conceive of individually and and so
that's my optimism and America is very
good at that
the Varick is very good at
entrepreneurial effort it's just that we
have forced it into this what I think is
a is a false paradigm that you're either
an entrepreneur and a businessman or you
are somehow you know a closeted academic
and doing things that have no relevance
to society great thank you thank you
very much Peter
you know you touched in your comments a
bit about children and and how we raise
our children and it occurs to me that in
some ways some of the the drive that we
see that individuals drive to success is
in part you know certainly in an
affluent community like West Los Angeles
it's not necessarily manifest as drive
for themselves but drive for their
children the drive to attend the best
school to have you know the the greatest
status to symbols to it's not
necessarily appetitive for oneself but
something that one tries to do for the
next generation and it occurs to me in
some ways that that we're not doing a
favor for the next generation by setting
that example that the the drive to
succeed and the drive to for consumption
is something that we tend to pass along
in the way that we raise our children
thoughts on and it's a very hard
treadmill I think to get off of because
once one is on it once one looks at
one's neighbors and sees oh well they're
doing this if I don't do this
my children will fall behind not me
sorry that all fall behind but my
children will thoughts on how to get off
of that kind of personal treadmill
well that's it's a tough one I think
that it is the natural instinct to try
to support one's children beyond oneself
but it's it's becoming increasingly
difficult of course as our society
bifurcates and we have very rich people
and very poor people but I think that
even within that effort to make sure
that one's children can cope in what is
an increasingly competitive society it's
entirely reasonable to have them also
participate in what they really want to
do one of the things that we tend to do
with children these days I believe is we
don't give them enough time to use their
own imagination they you know children
are curiously enough just as happy when
tiny playing with a saucepan and a
wooden spoon as they are playing with an
iPad the problem with the technical
wizardry that we have now especially
when we're all using it is that the
child sees their parents when they're
walking with their parents not talking
to them but talking to something in
their ear and you end up with the child
wanting to be like the parent and
wanting to actually have a similar
machine if you that tends to crowd out
the spaces that the kids have for just
thinking about nothing essentially and
I'm not quite sure how we get back to
that but there's considerable evidence
that childhood these days is very
different from the childhood that I had
for example where my parents would say
to me you know get off the doorstep and
get on your bike and come back in in
time for supper
that was that was I lived in the country
and that was perhaps easier and safer in
those days but the but we've got to
somehow I'm not I'm not a Luddite I
don't think we should go back to the
18th century I think however we've got
to ask ourselves how do we
space for children to think for
themselves how do we create an
opportunity for them to use their
imagination human imagination is a most
wonderful thing and when the child
begins to develop that they do it in a
very idiosyncratic way and I think that
we make a mistake by giving them too
many highly technical toys because it it
focuses them and shifts them in a
direction which is somebody else's
imagination not their own so I think
that we don't have to deprive them we
just have to give them opportunity to
think through things which we might not
be thinking through with them at the
moment you having a you know a music
lesson five times a week is not a way of
developing your imagination even though
you might be a good pianist at the end
of it great thank you very much
you spoke quite a bit about the
importance of social ties in developing
the kinds of values that you were
talking about for society we have one
question here about God and religion
where does God and religion fit into the
development of the well tuned brain and
an empathy and compassion can you can
you speak to those kinds of constructs
and how you see those fit again I think
that's that's also a very fascinating
subtopic I touch upon it some in the in
the chapter on imagination you know one
of the one of the interesting things
about human beings is we are able to
imagine ourselves in other places even
other worlds and I think that's the the
it's the connection that we see with
other generations that actually begins
the whole concept of religion it's it's
as one of my apologist friend says it's
it it's not important but it's central
religion is in its best form something
that binds society together and it's the
imaginative structure one might not
believe in virgin birth one may not
believe in in in such things
nonetheless the the ethos of the
organization of the religion does in
fact create a social contract and a
social structure which is
extraordinarily important for most of us
and so I think that if you if you stand
back far enough and say this is another
facet of the extraordinary ability to
have imagination look at the look at the
look at the cave paintings in southern
France which you know probably a thirty
forty thousand years old they have hands
on the wall next to the cracks in the in
the stone blown paint around hands which
obviously were there at one time there
are all sorts of theories about that but
one of them is that this was an effort
because they thought the previous
generations the the ancestors were in
that frame and you could get to them
through these caves through these cracks
in the wall so we have the imagination
that we can go on for generations and
you just reversed that and you think
about the future we can also go to
heaven so I think if if you think about
the way in which the human mind works is
nothing antithetical about religion it's
completely I don't believe in people who
think that oh if you're religious
you're not reasoning you are reasoning
you're using an imagination which is
different from the reasoning that you
might be using if you were trying to
develop some sort of scientific answer
to a objective question I think human
beings need they need mystery they need
ways in which they can see themselves
within a larger context and I think
that's what religion does great thank
you we have an interesting
[Music]
psychoanalytic question here you were
talking about the different layers of
the brain different parts of the brain
one question here is how does this
relate to Freud's theory about Edie ego
and superego
and does that do you tie in some of this
into Freud's psychoanalytic theories
I talked a little bit about Freud in the
book not a great deal in this book but
you know I think don't forget he was he
was living a hundred and more years ago
and he was really thinking about the way
in which society at that time in Vienna
was a very repressive society and I
think if he lived today his theories of
sexual interest would not probably fly
quite as well because we seem to see
that in every hotel room but I think
that I think that what he was doing was
he was resonating with this same idea
that have been there in the
Enlightenment thinkers that that you
have a core of the brain which is
primitive which in his mind would have
been the it'd and then beyond that you
have a ego which is essentially the way
in which the it'd and the brain itself
meld together because that's much more
related to the conscious day-to-day
functioning of course in his mind the
it'd was pre conscious or unconscious
but I don't think it's quite the same
way as we think of pre conscious
activity today but if you put those two
things together
then the self the super-ego is self
command that's something which again
Smith wrote a lot about in his Theory of
Moral Sentiments he recognized that the
child learns self command through
basically growing up to the point where
he realizes he's not the center of the
universe and if you read Freud's
theories about infantile sexuality etc
that is exactly what he's describing
only in slightly different language so I
think there's compatibility with
psychoanalytic theory and the way in
which we now see normal development
thank you
several of the questions this evening
have to do with the violence the
unspeakable violence over the past week
the
incredible acts of cruelty one does not
even want to call them terrorism they
were just outright murder of innocent
civilians people who clearly were
outside of the main social fabric of
their community who really committed
these horrific acts how how do the the
theories of your book and the the
concept of social fabric and and how and
or lack thereof relate to some of the
violence that we see so rampant in in
this country with guns or most recently
in Europe with the the horrible murders
in Paris I have to confess I haven't
thought deeply about that regarding the
Paris tragedy but I think that you put
your finger on it when you said that you
know I suspect that the individuals who
perpetrate such things are on the fringe
of their own religion in this case and
that becomes a justification in some
ways for their acts it it it's easier to
think about what happens here in this
country because if you think about most
of the mass shootings I mean one of the
one of the fascinating things again
which is a mystery to me about America
is that we we actually kill more people
in a year by about eight to ten times
than died have died in the Afghan and
Iraq Wars in total every year with
handguns so and then you have occasional
outbursts of the issue of individuals
who frequently sadly deranged
killing others in a in a squandered way
very similar to that went on in Paris
but you know if you think about it we
this is an example of a habit which goes
back to the 18th century I mean I was
not joking when I said that if we were
literal about interpreting the the
Constitution and the ability to carry
arms it would be that we all be carrying
muzzleloaders which might be usually
quite good because it takes quite a long
time to reload a muzzleloader
it's when you it's when you take
something which is habitual and you turn
it into something which is without
thinking brought up to the modern times
that you get into trouble we I think
we've created a market Society for
example where we don't think there
should be any breaks we think oh well
you know a free market is when basically
you can do what you please we don't of
course we have lots of regulations in
this country but I think regulation is
absolutely essential and one of the
other interesting things which I don't
create don't really haven't really
thought through but I think it's
something we need to think through is as
self command and Trust of each other
diminishes which it definitely is doing
you can see that then regulation
increases I mean that's clear that's
happening to us we've got more and more
regulations because we are not
regulating ourselves and so I think that
that when you've allowed the the the
thing to run amok so we've got so many
guns in this country we've got more guns
than we have people as I understand it
then we are in fact in a set of
circumstances where we we need
individual trust and caring in you know
there's there's the fascinating thing to
me is that apparently Canada has almost
as many guns per capita as we do but
apparently they have some sort of social
fabric which enables them not to shoot
each other quite so frequently so I
don't know what that all means but we
need to start thinking about it standing
back from the moral issue I deserve to
have a gun because you know it's in the
Constitution or in the
as opposed to the idea that these things
are extremely dangerous I don't know
that we can do very much about the the
situation in Paris except to recognize
that it's going to be a series of things
like that that we have to cope with
because it's a totally different vision
of what society is and we don't share
that Society so we have to oppose it and
I'm not sure how that will play itself
out but I think it's one of the
extraordinary challenges of our time
that we need to think about that as a
free society and how we can possibly
contain something that is so easily
perpetrated upon us now so thank you
thank you great answer to a difficult
question
one thing you you spoke about was if you
really want to understand your your
brother's suffering on the rack you need
to envision yourself on the rack you
need to put yourself in his place and
and one of the questions here I'm not
sure that I fully understand but I'll
put it out there is what do we do about
the deficit of empathy in this country
and I think that some of that relates
really to the mission of the friends in
terms of D stigmatizing mental illness
that is it seems that people have a
remarkable lack of empathy for those who
are suffering from depression psychosis
other major mental disorders and I think
it is hard for people to put themselves
in the position of those who are
mentally ill despite the fact that
everybody has been touched by mental
disorder thoughts about how to increase
empathy for in society in general
particularly for those suffering from
mental illness well you're asking me
some tough questions here I think this
is going to be easy I think that you
know empathy I'll come back to the point
of stigma but I think empathy is
actually something which begins very
early in life I mean I think if you look
at that picture of my granddaughter not
too
to chauvinistic about it but the fact is
that she was extraordinarily attached
that creature that she helped to bring
up and when the when the when the sheep
actually had a lamb of its own she was
terribly unhappy because she felt she'd
lost her little sister and the she's
only six years old at that time or five
when it happened but but the but the you
see there the early phases of a child's
integration with the social order and
wanting to be part of it and I think
that that's what we must foster you know
in a society where we're so busy it's
very difficult to engage at the empathic
level with children I mean I I say
sometimes to my people I'd try to help
and care for it doesn't really matter
whether you're chastising a child or
you're complimenting a child you've got
to be present with the child and then
they consider because they they learn
think of think about for example your
teachers in high school I talked about
this also in the book you probably all
of you can remember a teacher you had in
high school yes but you probably can't
remember a word of what they taught you
that the reason why you remember that
person is because they are they in your
are in your mind probably attached to
either a very positive thought usually
the case or a negative thought but it's
something to do with that social link
which makes you remember them
and that's what a child does when they
when they're looking for the social
links in their world they the first of
all draw upon those they have from their
parents and their siblings and then they
imagine them that's why they play these
little games you know with teddys coming
to tea and and Teddy's always spills his
teacup you know this is a big problem
with teddy
and and and and so that imagination that
he had that they have is the beginning
of empathic understanding of the fact
that teddy is a klutz
or and and so these I think that we need
again to nurture that and we can do that
by just being engaged with children when
you then get to to a situation and I've
gone and forgotten the second part of
your question the the the the way in
which as they grow up but an empathy for
those of mental disorders with with
those who who are sick if they if they
have engaged the idea of trying to
understand why you know aren't Mabel who
comes every Thanksgiving and gives them
something very nice but compare it with
uncle Charlie who comes and is always a
grouch
it's that sort of understanding which
then enables them to say why is that
person strange why is it that that
person seems to be distant from me then
they begin to if their parents are
thoughtful they can begin to understand
empathically what happens we don't do
nearly enough of that I mean we I joke
with my friends you know we walk past
people in the street yes who are
obviously seriously mentally ill you see
them in local restaurants I've had I've
had people come up to me in local
restaurants who have serious illness and
I but but the fact is that we don't
engage them as if they're real people I
remember a patient I had in Vermont once
she came in tied to a chair she had
mania tied to a chair by her family
because they didn't know whatever to do
with her she was completely crazed so
they were dumbstruck when I said untie
her please and and so they we untied her
and I went over to her and said and I
knew her name because they told me I
said mrs. Jones I'm doctor why brow and
she looked at me and she said oh the my
in a hospital it's suddenly the
engagement of a person at a human level
can have an extraordinary influence
we're either frightened or we haven't
had enough practice
great we have lots more questions but
I'm just want to pick one more here and
that is what would you really like to
see come out of the information that you
present in this book there there are
many many messages here if you if you
had to distill out what message you'd
like to see come from this that would be
absorbed by society and might lead to
some changes what would that lesson or
what were those lessons look like Andy I
think that the you know in some ways
this book is a template for what we're
trying to do with the healthy campus
initiative and with the mind/body
program in the sense that I think that
we're flexible throughout life it I when
I use the metaphor of the well-tuned
brain it's a lifelong effort and I think
if it's the most fascinating thing you
can do because to know yourself better
and to be able to care for others in a
in a balanced way this doesn't mean that
it everything's will come by or it just
means that you can be objective about
you know some people in the world are
evil some people you don't like I mean
all of course that's true but I think if
you can if you can learn that about
yourself then you can provide an
opportunity for others to relate to you
in an objective way without disturbance
and I think we need to try to teach that
at a university I think it is I think it
is something that can be taught and I
think it should start early on in
childhood it should start in the
parental family it should start in the
local community etc etc but even if it
hasn't I think this thing's are still
flexible enough by the time you get to
UCLA you could still learn some things
and I think one of the things that Jane
particularly has tried to Jane someone
has particularly tried to do is to is to
foster that idea of course we do good
science of course we know we are
pursuing the vulnerabilities that people
that create mental illness you're not
going to solve problems by this alone we
need to know how developmental disorders
begin we need to know how degeneration
occurs in the central nervous system we
know all those things and once we know
all those things we can then find ways
in which we can improve them but in but
in general we also need to maintain a
sense of what it is that the human
person can do I'm I think human beings
are extraordinary creatures and I think
we we have extraordinary gifts and I
think that we as I said at the very
beginning of the talk we have left we
have lost some of our best attributes in
the last few years we as we've been
washed over by increasing frenzy and
Technic technologies if we could if we
could change that here in America we
would be actually providing something
which was written in the early
declaration we didn't like King George
because he was a he was from the top
down we liked from the bottom up and we
have to be careful we don't slip into
just being a top down Society again and
so I think we can do that at a
university we can say if people remember
what they learned here when they become
CEOs or or whatever they are leaders
they will be also caring of the
individuals who they work with
great thank you wonderful answer
in just a moment we're going to close
the program and invite you to join dr. Y
Brown in the foyer where you can
purchase and get him to sign your book
but first I want to thank you very much
dr. Bob Rafferty has a wonderful
presentation and and a lively discussion
of C I think very challenging questions
that you raised in your book and thank
you very much for participating in the
program this evening thank you so I very
much want to thank the friends were
putting on the program this evening and
to all of you who have come out to hear
dr. Y Brown and I know that many of you
come to a number of our programs
throughout the course of the year
as Vicki pointed out in her comments at
the beginning we really do not receive
support from the University from the
state to put on these programs we really
rely upon your generosity in order to
put these programs on and continue to
provide them free to the public so
please at the holiday season if you
would take a moment to pick up an
envelope in the foyer and give us
generously as you can to the friends to
help us continue our educational mission
we'd very much appreciate it once again
many many thanks for coming out and
enjoy the rest of your evening
thank you
[Applause]